so let's set up a relationship between
the variables x and y
so let's say
so this is x
and this is y and when x is one
y is four and when x is two
y is 8 and when x is 3
y is 12. now you might immediately
recognize that this is a proportional
relationship and remember in order for
it to be a proportional relationship the
ratio between the two variables is
always constant so for example if i look
at y over x here we see that y over x
here it's four over one which is just
four eight over two is just four eight
halves is the same thing as four twelve
over three is the same thing as 4. y
over x is always equal to 4. in fact i
can make another column here i can make
another column here where i have y over
x here it's 4 over 1
which is equal to 4. here it's 8 over 2
which is equal to 4. here's 12 over 3
which is equal to 4.
and so you can actually use this
information the ratio the ratio between
y and x is this constant 4 to express
the relationship between y and x as an
equation in fact in some ways this is or
in a lot of ways this is already an
equation but i can make it a little bit
clearer if i multiply both sides by x if
i multiply both sides by x
if i multiply both sides by x i am left
with well x divided by x you just have y
on the left hand side y is equal to 4x
and you see that's the case x is one
four times that is four x is two four
times that is eight so here you go we're
multiplying by four
we are multiplying by four
we are multiplying by four
and so four in this case
four in this case in this situation this
is our constant of proportionality
constant
constant sometimes people will say
proportionality constant constant of
proportionality
portionality now sometimes it might even
be described as a rate of change you're
like well sal how is this a how would
four be a rate of change and to make
that a little bit clearer let me
actually do another example but this
time i'll actually put some units there
so let's say that
let's say that i have
let's say that x let me decide to use
yellow let me use blue
so let's x let's say that's a measure of
time
and y
is a measure of distance
or let me put it this way x is time in
terms of seconds
let me write it this way
so x
x is going to be in seconds and then y
is going to be in meters
so this is meters
the units and this right over here is
seconds
so after one second we have traveled i
don't know
seven meters after two seconds we've
traveled 14 meters after three seconds
we've traveled 21 meters and you can
verify that this is a proportional
relationship the ratio between y and x
is always seven seven over one fourteen
over two twenty 21 over 3. but i want to
write that in terms of its units so y
over x
is going to be if we look at this point
right over here it's seven meters over
one second
seven
meters over one second or it's equal to
seven
meters per second if you look at it
right over here if you say y over x
it's 14 meters
14 meters in two seconds
in two seconds well 14 over 2 is 7.
14 over 2 is 7 and then the units are
meters per second
so that's why this constant the 7 in all
of these cases we have y over x is equal
to 7 that this is also sometimes
considered a rate and over here it's
very clear this is a my distance per
time now if i wanted to write it
generally i could say that look if i'm
dealing with a proportional relationship
it's going to be of the form i can
always construct an equation of the form
of the form either y over x is equal to
k
where k is some constant in this first
example k was equal to 4 and this is a
second example k is equal to 7 or you
can just manipulate it algebraically
multiply both sides by x and you would
have y is equal to
y is equal to kx
where once again k is our constant of
proportionality or proportionality
constant so this is a really in some
ways it's a very simple idea but in a
lot of ways you'll see this showing up
multiple multi many many times in your
mathematical career it's neat to be able
to recognize this as a proportional
relationship